the five-star cruise ship ms europa
graces the belgian port of antwerp it's
on route from Lisbon to Hamburg and this
is to be the 10th annual maritime
meeting of Europe's gourmet elite the
special cruise brings ten of the
continents top chefs on board the Europa
with a total of fourteen Michelin stars
among them
before the Sun seldom shipment on board
ship of course they fulfill your hearts
every desire this is so something very
special and we love it I thought this is
unique I've never experienced anything
like this it's our first time on the
Europa the chance to experience this and
the best chefs on earth is just fabulous
a feast for the senses I was really
surprised because this is my first time
here and I was really surprised that
there are first of all so many star
shows here and the variety is really
really good so I was really happy to be
here
pickled white slice of halibut on
fragrant rice and pineapple mango
chutney is the creation of three-star
chef haha vote fraud one of the world's
best it's nice to be able to offer the
guests a taste of the spots by Shuba and
bio spawn yep let's the oven pad d
tamura is another three-star chef his
creation cochina curry and lemongrass
cappuccino with a scampi stew and
grilled skewer of soul dieter Muller
will be cooking in his own kitchen he's
been running a restaurant on board since
2010 making him the world's only
michelin-starred chef on the high seas
the reason he says is simple zynga this
is I think once you've achieved
everything you can on land it's nice if
you still want to see more of the world
kenza lung and pamper guests without
cuisine like this but the real host on
board is Stefan buca a chef de cuisine
on the europa he's in charge of for
gourmet restaurants he first came on
board in 2004 and by 2006 he was
appointed head chef
you know misses me so it's not exactly
like we can take it easy normally I'm in
the galley down below there we work on a
lot more variations cutting me off most
of the chefs arrived the day before to
start their meticulous preparations it's
one of the most hectic phases of the
whole event you free me up I completely
feel like a host because I try to give
every guest chef everything they need in
advance when they come on board they'll
find everything they need for their
recipes in the amounts they need I also
ensure the chef's themselves get
something to eat and drink some of them
forget to order simple items also so I
make sure there's a blender for every
guest chef maybe even two after all we
have to help each other wherever we can
that was something is missing on the
line that was heavy besides the chef
there are wine stewards shot Gotye and
ice cream specialists to spoil the
guests on the Lido deck that does go Mia
fest for us of course the gourmet
festival is not just the crowning event
but a real distinction and for every
gourmet event the presence of behad
Antony is obligatory a cheese Pope as
he's known arrived from southern France
there are 30 varieties all naturally
aged hard cheese soft cheese goats and
sheeps cheese all from different
families and enough of everything as
always the gourmet festival on board the
MS Europa concludes with a party that
goes long into the night it's topped off
by fireworks to complement those to the
palette